oh really glad the season remember that
my girl Scorpius a princess dang right
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody
sheera season four actually like a full
proper season because let's be honest
seasons 1 & 2 we're really just one
season split into two halves and sold to
us at half price or half length or this
metaphor is broken down on me in any
case this is really season 3 we're
calling a season 4 it has been released
i binge through it in 2 evening sessions
and like this show that said I do have
notes and if that surprises you at all
you must be new here but anyway let's
start good first of all I continue to
love legions designs I love these
characters I love this visual style I
love the voice work I love being in this
world with these people I really really
enjoy it so that I got all that flooding
back to me tone wise this one's on the
heavier side if I were to make a
relative comparison to it this is
basically the Empire Strikes Back of the
sheera so far which I'm not really going
to spoiler that comment because if you
saw season 3 and saw how that ended
you should have guessed things were
gonna get rough coming into season 4 I
am gonna get into spoilers eventually
but I will give you a heads up before I
get into that so we come into this
season with a couple of significant
differences the relationship between the
characters at the hoard are kind of
fractured and fragmented even though the
hoard itself is possibly in a strongest
position at
been so far the rebellion is in a rough
place because this is only spoiler if
you haven't seen season three you have
in which case why are you watching this
because of the death of an jela at the
end of the previous season they bright
moon now wow I was gonna say it doesn't
have a queen it does glimmer gets
crowned queen that's happens in the very
first episode but she's put in a
position that she hasn't had before
which is she doesn't have anyone to
answer to anymore and that really does
weigh on glitter glimmer in interesting
ways for a number of reasons because of
how it distances her from her friends
because you don't send the lead of an
army out on missions that would be dumb
so she's not with them and sort of
reaffirming their connections as often
and also like kind of a big part of her
inherent Drive was making a decision
relative to what her mother wanted and
so oftentimes it would strengthen her to
know she was doing something that her
mother said was a bad idea well there's
nobody above her anymore
she's got nothing to rebell against and
that kind of puts her in a bit of an odd
place and she's got a lot of stuff to
sort through and they tackle that in I
think fairly decent ways in fairly
interesting ways bow and adora are great
and awesome and doing their things start
to finish they do some interesting
things with light hope in terms of some
more that we learn because we've still
got a fair bit of backstory about what
the exact deal with Shira and the sword
and the first ones is we got a bit of
that last season we get quite a bit more
of it here to the point that we have
most of a complete picture at this point
I would say now there are some new
characters and well there's one
primarily there's two there is a new
heroic character named flood arena who
gets introduced and there is a villain
character called double trouble who is
more the one that I kind of want to
focus on right now flutter Rena is chief
she's fluttery and she's a good guy whew
double trouble
is a character that a lot of people who
know me have been asking me about
already because Double Trouble is
referred to as they and is demonstrable
gender-fluid because they are a
shapeshifter
and you know basically of the Mystics a
perfect recreation
although can also tweak it and do
exaggerated if they decide to do that
now here's where one of the notes come
in I don't really like Double Trouble
all that much in terms of
characterization I like what they do for
the narrative I like them in terms of
the storylines and what they drive and
what is impacted by their presence and
how I also like their there the impact
of their presence on Katra specifically
but as a character I don't really like
them all that much and I don't think it
has anything to do with the gender
aspect just to tackle that everyone just
refers to Double Trouble is the bay and
leaves it at that nobody questions it
attention has ever brought to it it's
just how everyone refers to them which
makes sense given what they're capable
of and that for all intents and purposes
they either have no gender or they are
all genders so if beings like this exist
having a beast just standard to call
someone like that day makes total sense
that I'm on board with that what I don't
like about the characterization is the
fact that it leans very heavily on what
is to my mind a very base level parody
of a performer or an actor you know
they're always going about oh I'm
getting into character and despite the
you know gender ambiguity the app-v
vocal affectation is very theater gay I
I don't I'm not I'd I know nothing about
the performer I don't know who the voice
actor was I know nothing about their
history I don't know if they are gender
fluid or gender queer or anything else
I'm only talking about the vocal
performance that and performance that
they delivered and that vocal
performance
I'm sorry it's very theater gay is right
oh well I can I can bring this to the
pot this will be my greatest challenge
and I don't enjoy that characterization
I find it baseless I find it basic I
find it tropi and speaking as a theater
person it just I just kind of like yeah
it's it's just one of those things that
just feels very shallow then and there's
nothing really wrong with the decision
to characterize the character as a
performer but it's it I just I just
don't like I don't like the vocal
performance again not because the voice
acting is bad in any traditional sense
just because the acting choices made
result in a characterization that I
don't enjoy I don't have fun with it
wasn't painful I did it wasn't like I
groaned every time they showed up but I
wasn't excited to see them either so
that for me makes Double Trouble one of
the weaker characters on the show which
bugs me because yes kind of on principle
I would really like to have hooked in
and really loved the gender-fluid
character but I don't so you know that's
reality and we move on I am gonna have
to start getting a bit into spoilers
with my other thoughts both positive and
negative so if you haven't seen this
season yet you might want to go stop off
and do that if you're sticking around
I'm assuming you've either seen it or
you don't care about spoilers so yeah
let's do that
so spoilers here we go so for me the
best episode in this season was Raz I
really loved what they did with madam
Raz and both logística Lee and I thought
it actually got some good emotional
beats out of it I love that it's
presented and it never explained
flat-out just presented as she's
effectively unstuck in time and we know
it's that and not just a matter of she
keeps flashing back tomorrow while
talking to a Dora because she calls
Maura a Dora
she hadn't met yet at that point in time
so she is somehow unstuck from time as a
human being and she keeps flitting back
and forth and dealing with the sheera of
an era Mara in the past adore in the
present and to what degree raise herself
who can wrap her head around what's
going on it's hard to know she seems to
have some grasp on it but she's really
bad at explaining it to anybody or maybe
she just feels it's not worth the bother
who knows she is slightly crazy but it
all makes a lot of sense now why she's
confusing
adora with Mara why she's connecting
with them and the whole thing of her
wanting just wanting to bake a pie and
like just keep coming back to that
you're talking tomorrow when
everything's falling apart and talking
to a door who's desperately trying to
figure out how to fix what's going on
she and Raz just keeps Reese entering
herself on the pie and I choked up when
Mara when Mara realized that Raz didn't
get that Mara was dying and was not
going to see her again and that she just
says Raz Raz will make the pie tomorrow
I promise oh that hurt but in the best
way that was great I really to me that
episode was the highlight of the season
there are other good episodes as well I
mentioned Skorpio and yes I do like what
they did with Scorpio hi another really
powerful moment the episode as a whole
didn't hit me as hard but a really
powerful moment and I was like so proud
of her as a character is Scorpia
confronting Katra and just saying with
this frown on her face you're a bad
friend
after that she leaves and not even with
a goal of changing sides just knowing
that she can't help Katra where she is
and maybe if she can get entrapped of
back things will be better again and
Katra won't go to get entrapped Oh
social she'll go to the princesses to it
I like that the moral concept of good
guys bad guys isn't a factor in what
scorpius doing Scorpius trying to be a
good friend that is her goal that is
what she wants and the decision to leave
Katra is still rooted in that and I love
that I love that so much and Katra oh
man
like k Katra is not fun the way she used
to be fun she's not hey Dora fun anymore
but Wow
watching her come apart is really well
done and really compelling so it's very
clear now that Katra is is on a
self-perpetuating cycle of self-hatred
and isolation because she goes in to any
given relationship and I don't
necessarily mean romantic I mean any
connection any relationship with other
people and at this point whether or not
she was always like this is hard to say
she might have been a bit like this
before a door left back in season one
but she's definitely like this now where
it is her basic operating assumption
that nobody actually likes her and that
it's not worth it for her to try and
have friends and that everyone's just
gonna leave her and disappoint her or
use her or abuse her anyways and what
that means is when someone like Scorpia
comes along and genuinely tries to be
her friend capture just keeps pushing
her away and pushing her away and
pushing her away and pushing her away
until the point where Scorpia does in
fact leave again not necessarily because
she was never willing to come back or be
her friend anymore but because this this
wasn't working
so Scorpia left and instead of becoming
a moment of realizing oh my god I drove
her away it becomes an affirmation for
her to believe everything that she was
saying that caused her to behave that
way in the first place so she pushes and
pushes and pushes you're gonna leave me
you're gonna leave too
nobody cares about me and she says it
enough that says it hard enough until
people do actually leave because
eventually you know they're gonna need
to self care and take a step away and
then she just goes see I didn't need you
I was better off without you because you
left like I said you would and I wish I
could say that I have never seen that in
life but I have and it's very well
captured here it's really really just on
the money as far as that goes while also
acknowledging that that hardness does
not insulate her from her feelings she
is lonely part of her does want these
connections but her armor is to push
them away even as part of her and the
back of her head is going please stay
please stay please stay even as she's
pushing so become simultaneously an
affirmation of the fact that they will
always leave in a test to see if they
will or they won't and in her mind
everyone fails the test and she she
doesn't make the extension I don't have
to test people until they break but she
is so damaged Wow the stuff that went on
with glimmer was pretty well done I
called it very early on it's a little
bit of a dark willow arc but it was well
executed for what it was even though it
was it was easy to call I also liked
that mer Mistah got very hard-edged in
the wake of her home being conquered by
the Horde and that was another thing
this was the first season where it
legitimately felt like the Horde was
winning
it's kind of been a little bit of a
back-and-forth up to this point it felt
like okay maybe the Horde like still has
a lot of territory but we've got our you
know we've got all this stuff that we
control and the rebels um you know are
protecting but they started actually
losing that this season so the Horde
feels like I'm much more legitimate
right now Oh another episode I liked a
lot I liked the one that focused on the
Horde trio of Kyle Roy halee oh and
Lonnie that was that was good stuff too
I liked getting a highlight on them and
real and reaffirming those three
characters and their connection and how
they worked and that was just a lot of
fun and also that did end up feeding a
bit into catch a story which was good
stuff Hordak oh boy he's yeah he's a
little bit on the edge to it and was
also kind of interesting for me for him
that Katra is basically kind of
manipulating him to be more aggressive
because what catcher keeps telling
yourself is if I can just get that then
I'll be happy then it'll be good like me
and the gold she keeps moving her own
goalpost and keeps insisting you know if
we just conquer this territory now if we
conquer this one and this one if we just
wipe out the row but she will never be
happy no matter what but she will not
face that but she she gets Hordak out in
the field only to have him kind of enjoy
it and then that throws off her ability
to have complete control about what's
going on in the field and it never comes
across as like Hordak is being a [ __ ]
being manipulated but the guys got a
laser focus on what he wants so he's a
little bit he's got blinders on a little
bit I do like that they finally equipped
him with the arm cannon that he had in
the old show that was cool to see horde
Prime finally showing up at the end and
loved his design I don't know if it's
the design of the color I don't think I
like the green the green doesn't the
green just kind of bleeds into the white
one that ice is about horde acts design
is he has stark red and black clashing
with the you know the very pale skin he
has where his horde prime he's still got
that paleness but it's green and the
green just kind of bleeds into it it's
not the the stark contrast of the red
in the black and so I don't like court
prime to design all that much one of the
few designs I don't really care for so
but we'll also see where that goes I
think the one other thing that I would
say that kind of made me go a little bit
this season was that the overall threat
in the tail end of the climax of the
planet being balanced and that
unleashing power that would basically
destroy everything was functionally
incredibly similar to the portal at the
end of the previous season like I
understand that specifics bits and
pieces are different and you know the
the way it's activate is different the
resolution is different and the
characters that the center of it are
different because that one was initiated
by kachra this one is much more got
glimmer and light hope and a door at the
heart of it as opposed to just catch her
in a door last season but functionally
narrative Lee it's doing effectively the
same thing great big threat that's gonna
destroy the world oh my god how do we
stop it and I so I don't love that the
end of this season just felt very
similar again I know all the narrative
little differences in tweaks and
whatever but it just felt very similar
and that I I don't love I would have
liked to have had a finale that was
different before we did something at
that callback to that as much as this
kind of does it does leave things in an
interesting ending point like where the
heck do we go from here but entrapped is
back so that's great Mike is back how's
that gonna pan out God hose glimmer
gonna react to that swords gone I'm
assuming light hope is gone there's a
lot that happened by the end of this
thing I will be very curious to see
where things pick up from here and I
really do like it even though on balance
I don't know if I would say this is my
least favorite season it's the season I
have the most notes for so I suppose it
is by default I still really like it
though I really do like the show and
I hope they announce it next season soon
and I hope it happens relatively quickly
and I I love this show sheera season 4
you seen it what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it this video is sponsored by my
own patreon page because without your
support I'm not sure I could keep this
nonsense going so if you are able to
help me out that way
there's a link down below and that would
greatly be appreciated even if you can't
like subscribe share the video around
that also helps and it appeases the
almighty algorithm so there's links down
below all those things click on things
buttons links comments do it or don't
you don't have to at the end of the day
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]